but I'm a wildlife warrior you know I
was born into wildlife farm I eat sleep
and live for conservation I'd treat that
croc like I treat my daughter like a
treat you like I treat my wife like I
treat anyone and I can hear my dad's
words in the background they are gonna
kick your bottom if you go complacent
anyway I got complacent
we're conservationists mate through and
through like we live for conservation
and our message is so strong for Muncie
scratching his head how come that kid
never got killed by that brown snake and
and I guess he figured it out then he's
figured this kid's got something I won't
eat I will just I'll stay on that River
because I feel so passionate about
catching that croc before someone gets
to him some people would like to call me
an actor I think sigh all I gotta do is
go out there and do this when always the
tiniest little kid angel look up with my
dad and you know he was like larger than
life he was just like these action hero
and this isn't some joy an ego trip
uh-uh it's just that I gotta get the
camera I've got to be right in there
right so what I'm gonna do is I get
close enough Mike I'm gonna grab it
round the neck then you're gonna have to
skew the tile otherwise I can get killed
Roger
he was an Australian wildlife expert TV
personality and conservationist he
achieved worldwide fame for his TV
series the Crocodile Hunter the sea
Shepherd Conservation Society ship my
Steve Irwin was named in his honor he's
Steve Irwin and here his top ten rules
for success yeah it's kind of a juggling
act yeah you know that you know
balancing wildlife always will be but
I'm a wildlife warrior you know I was
born into wildlife I eat sleep and live
for conservation so I'm just running
around all over the paddock no matter
which country I'm in trying to conserve
wilderness areas and look after trees
and flora and the oceans and which I
guess in essence is really good for
wildlife but it's also good for Humanity
for without trees and and nice clean
oceans and a lot of animals it would be
a very sad place to live our my
philosophy and fatherhood
you know I just treat her exactly the
same way as I would want to be treated
and you know the funny thing is Andy I
treat my wildlife
the same you know like if there was a
croc there I'd treat that croc like I
treat my daughter like a treat you like
I treat my wife like a treat anyone oh I
treat things how I in turn would want to
be treated some or little kid I just
treated around I want to be treated you
know my mom said you know you can't have
ice cream for breakfast yeah sweetheart
absolutely you want to catch that snake
sure it's venomous but we'll do it and
I'll show you how and we'll do it and we
did it you have animals in the house
don't you [ __ ] might work she kind of
placed her carpet snake at one point a
bit of rot on the face of first snake
bite she's a snake maniac but my kid my
daughter's a snake free she loves snakes
at favorite animal this night you know
born and raised with snakes so you know
here's this carpet python coming across
the road at night we're going after
Poppy's house and she's oh my god daddy
daddy you know I said yeah don't worry
swear that I'll save us I'll run out
there I grabbed the snake and she starts
whinging you know all of the snake not
the snakes you know all right sweetheart
yeah but what's he had he's a bit body
and she grabs it and she starts singing
rock-a-bye baby like this I guess yeah
bites a rod on it which is like I say I
told you sweetheart
college is gonna bite you it's like take
a dead Rock right on home
let it go dude okay the back Kimmy's
blood all born down there I was very
proud of it I spent a long time in the
bush and I've caught a whole series of
crocodiles and with that came a big
heads and complacency and of course
never the to show me
catching Crocs and complacency is just
not on and I can hear my dad's words in
the background they are gonna kick your
bottom if you go complacent anyway I got
complacent I think he'd been in the bush
of it too long because he got very
complacent and he hadn't secured it
although he got this crocodile back from
him ready to put into a crate she was
she was still in the trap but she hadn't
been secured and now everything's
secured so while he's getting the
transport Creperie he let this croc out
of the trap and she was just sitting
there so he goes in the box as I'm back
down what
she put a series of rule beaut holes in
my feet all the way to the bite
thanks a lot and I had to bring my dad
and so wrong I bought dad I need some
help
cuz you need some help Jesus doesn't
sound like young Stevo that cotton all
did to me suey so he was extremely
fortunate that they're all he had in
each foot with some holes and he also
still had the crop that did could have
just walked off back to the creek where
conservationists make
through-and-through like we live for
conservation our message is so strong
really we're saving the world which is
look have a go what's happening right
you know we dark cloud of terrorism you
know September 11th and I like line
stuff and here's this bike from the bush
jump in beer wire Queensland have it a
go and bring in goodness into the world
you know wildlife wilderness
conservation greening up the earth yeah
your dad actually reckons you've got a
gift yeah an animal instinct which
enables you to deal with animals
what is that gift either yeah well um
dad was kind of the first one to notice
it and and good on him yeah I'm just a
product of my parents in my environment
and I was four years old and dad was
catching snakes for the then
Commonwealth serum laboratory right he
was looking for brown snakes and tiger
snakes and a place called bulla in
Victoria and um
so we're looking for tiger snakes and
brown snakes and I'm like I'm four years
old I'm rattling around he'll helping
him but you know I was playing imaginary
games imaginary armies you know I'm
shooting back at the it was Japanese
back then because my grandfather
great-grandfather died in World War two
cellars the Japanese or something
whatever please don't yeah like I've got
I Drive a Toyota
and he's this huge brown snake our
absolute whopper well I have a five-foot
soft come upon I'm gone oh yeah oh oh
yeah dad dad I go why don't I go one
he's like why does he own event he comes
well is that here's this brown snake a
me and it's up on my [ __ ] like I'm
wearing a plastic sandals no slots
either and here's this brown snake with
his head right on my leg and I've got a
pin and it's a whopper it's almost as
thick as my dad's wrist and he's gone
whack you know I'm belted me out of the
way crush me like a bug yeah cuz I
thought I'd I've got this brown snake
for him I thought I was gonna come out
of this a hero and he decks me but he
thought he saved my life and you know
for months he's scratching his head how
come that kid never got killed by that
brown snake and and I guess he figured
it out then he's figured his kids got
something so you know he's watch this
develop then mum and dad just propped me
up just prop me up every time I'd make
mistakes they just keep you know hang in
there hang in there lad hang in there
and they just kept helping me and
persuading me to follow my passion which
was wildlife and that in essence you
know helped me to be Who I am I've found
that the best way to catch a crocodile
is to treat it as a one-on-one situation
so I focus I just focus on that
crocodile so hard that I am unaware of
anything around me I won't eat I will
just I'll stay on that River because I
feel so passionate about catching that
croc before someone gets to him I just
won't stop I just got to do it and
yeah when I win it when that clock goes
into the trap and I've trapped him by
the light it's like it's quite a it's
almost an adrenaline surge to the act of
catching the crop because you know that
you've secured the animal and that he's
gonna live a really happy life and I was
born and raised as I am you know I can't
help Who I am I really can't you know
I'm steve-o and same bloke and I guess
when I was nine you know I caught my
first crocodile or you know two months
ago when I caught my 358 crocodile I
haven't changed mate I haven't changed
one little bit now here's the beauty of
the film here's the art the trick the
genius John Staton he actually not only
did he like write the whole thing and
direct it and produce it he also is the
genius behind Stephen what he did was he
didn't let me read the script he didn't
let me read the story in essence what he
did he created nothing he just created
nothing absolutely nothing I went into
the film exactly as I am now and just
went and just so I just breezed through
it oh just breathe straight through
collision course being steve-o on the
crocodile owner I didn't have to change
so what a coup what a coup you know some
people would like to call me an actor I
don't think so all I gotta do is go out
there and do this yeah just be me
you truly adore your parents don't you I
love my parents just so much mate I you
know like my mum how'd you be you know I
was born on her birthday and and all she
ever did was just love me and prop me up
and get me back out in there and my dad
just the legend of the universe when I
was the tiniest little kid Android
looked up at my dad and you know he was
like larger than life he was just like
this action hero he was everything I
wanted to be and all I've done in my
life is following his footsteps minikin
and try to be him and nowadays I just
try to make him proud night yeah I love
my parents
like like nothing else it's just they
are everything to me absolutely
everything in the day that my mum the
when was the Daiya blossom blossom was
something really big in my life dealing
with wildlife
I've been gored gourd chomped bitten
savaged jumped on what peed on even
great and every single time it's been my
fault if I get bitten I've made the
mistake I knew what I was up against
when I went in on that animal and it's
been a giant learning curve for me I
jumped on a crocodile and it was a bad
jump under the water whack hit me in the
head scarred me here I got scars all
over my face
Terry tore my earring up no two fingers
are the same they've been snapped split
chomped nails ripped off have a look at
my hands
virtually scars on the scars you can't
see the last bite because it's scar on
scar and this isn't some giant ego trip
uh-uh it's just that I got to get the
camera I've got to be right in there I
have to get right fear smack into the
action because this day has come where
the audience you need to come with me
and be there with that animal if there's
whales dying on the beach on the western
side of Tasmania I want to share it with
you because if we can touch people about
wildlife then they want to save it if
you go to SeaWorld and you get to have
an encounter with a dolphin
you want to save dolphins gone are the
days of sitting back on the long lens on
the tripod and look at it
what way over there
come with me share it with me share my
wildlife with me because humans want to
say things that they love my job my
mission the reason I've been put onto
this planet is to save wildlife
with okay can I go in heart on like
saying pretend crocodile I'll take you
be Terry Mike I'll walk you through it
okay it's all about picking them up in
the spot like getting close enough I'll
take the head in but for me to stay
alive you'll have to hit hard on the
tail-end my boy Boyd I come out the back
I've got a special Rove live crocodile
area set up by out this way ride a bike
so when did you first learn how to
wrestle a croc when I was nine nice
knowing years old mate your dad yeah dad
out the front of the boat he's gone you
get this one son good boy me walk okay
so here it is now don't get too scared
if you think you can handle it so let's
say there's a croc there it is in the
combi shoot if you're gonna get in it's
only a 6 for termite this shouldn't be
too long so take me through watch what
you're gonna do we're just gonna get to
Steve's equipment on so he doesn't
electrocute himself it's all about
reality mate ladies first thing you do
is you pick up their eye shine and then
when I've located their eye shine then
I'll put my spotlight there and you'll
have to keep yours on to the last points
in louvain radio but some just sneak
around here make you don't want to hit
him in the side right so what I'm gonna
do is is soon as I get close enough Mike
I'm gonna grab it round the neck then
you're gonna have to secure the tile
otherwise I didn't get killed
you're right I like going right
like immediately
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Steve Irwin for 477
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which is Steve's
top ten rules had the biggest impact on
you what change is gonna make in your
life for your business leave it in the
comments and I'll join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching and
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
do you have moments of repose moments of
just I'll just take it in and sit
quietly nah you know I got I have to do
a lot of plane flies yeah and uh oh
I'm a handful I don't know I I haven't
made it in the tabloids as the bloke who
started the riots and stuff on the
planes yet but I guarantee you it will
happen you know you can't you can't hang
your arm out the window and you can't
stop and have a pee and look at the
wildlife yeah you know you're stuck in
this thing for like sometimes 14 hours
in a leg you know like going to
America's just it's a 14-hour stint
maintenance shock and awful to sit there
and all that you know you can't I'm just
you know I like a good movie but not
five of them you know right now you know
I don't read much you know like I'm just
you don't read how come you know like
well I do read but no you know like not
for 14 hours
you know surf mags take a good 20
minutes I absolutely thrived on it
living right in the bush I became at one
with nature and I think those years of
isolation in the bush trying to help
crocodiles built Steve Irwin and I had
to use bush tucker
and I'd resort to fishing together to
get a fee so it really had really honed
my bush skills if there's one thing that
I Steve Irwin would want to be
remembered for its be remembered for
passion and enthusiasm conservation is
my job my life my whole persona